if you've been reading the news for any
measure of time then you're aware that
James Gunn is one of the new heads at DC
films now whether or not this is good
news is really up to you but in this
video I want to talk about this
specifically I want to talk about
Superman focusing on what DC films
previously got wrong and how James Gunn
can make the Man of Steel more in line
with what Superman is supposed to be
about
so my complaints about the depiction of
Superman from his introduction during
the Man of Steel up until now are not
that different from many others while I
think Henry Cavill was an amazing
casting Choice his character was written
as a flawed superhero more in line with
uh brooding or cynical person in fact I
agree with screen Hub when they were
writing about the Man of Steel film and
they said Clark Kent opens up the movie
as a Drifter unsure of his place in the
world much like Bruce Wayne in Batman
Begins These Quiet parts are the
strongest part of the film offering a
bit more more exploration into a figure
who's a product of two worlds but a
member of none indeed there was a somber
tone to these moments that brought a
level of humanity to an inhuman being
but despite the beauty of these moments
everything else completely missed the
point of Superman even as the film
progressed and Lois Lane was introduced
as the anchor that brought Superman back
to the world he stepped into the role of
a superhero unwillingly he had no desire
to fight General Zod or his forces even
knowing what they would do to the world
but even when the battle came it
contained no semblance of Hope or a
brighter tomorrow
where this could have been written off
as Superman figuring himself out his
subsequent appearances all had the same
tone dark brooding and cynical
the question of whether or not Humanity
was worth saving permeated every single
appearance he had and transformed the
Man of Steel into the man of misanthropy
what's funny is that this was by Design
in 2018 Screen Rant posted an article
where Zack Snyder confirmed to a fan
that Injustice was the inspiration for
Batman's vision of the future in Batman
vs Superman dawn of Justice but Batman's
Vision combined with the overall tone of
everything point to the idea that
Injustice was Snyder's inspiration for
his entire depiction of the DC Universe
and if this really is true then that's a
problem Injustice was a story where the
Joker tricked Superman into killing his
wife an unborn child which basically
sent him down the path of becoming a
ruthless dictator but the reason
Injustice was so significant was that it
was not a normal Superman the story
stood in stark contrast to the Superman
that we knew which made the death of his
family all the more tragic and his
response even more shocking but it's not
the story to use as a model for the Man
of Steel because Superman is not dark
he's not brooding and he's not cynical
in fact he's the exact opposite to my
point about Superman searching for
identity in 2013 Ryan Truitt wrote an
article for a USA Today titled why
Superman is the greatest American hero
in the article Truett wrote searching
for identity is a very human concept for
sure but what makes Superman and his
alter ego Clark Kent the ultimate
American Hero is that he reflected our
culture and Society ever since his first
appearance in Action Comics number one
in 1938 his Crash Landing in a cornfield
is a baby being raised by two Kansas
farmers is in a way the story of the
American immigrant in the same article
Julian chambliss a history professor at
Rollins university said the core
narrative in Superman always has and
continues to be the values and belief
about the US experience being strong
enough and good enough to address the
Troubles of the generation engaged with
his character and comic book writer Mark
Wade added Superman marched with the
troops and fought the Axis powers during
World War II but he was also a reaction
to industrialization to the power of big
business he was created as a social
agitator a character who fought for the
oppressed and the weak in the 1950s
Superman went from anti-authority to a
kind of uber cop since the post-war era
is where we saw ourselves as the world's
peacekeepers and in the 1960s and 70s
had stories that touched on the
counterculture and young people not
really having a sense of who they were
or where they were going the reason I
say all this is that Superman satisfies
our inner child yearning to be saved
from the struggles that plague us
Superman represents hope and while
almost none of Superman's appearances in
the dceu quite lived up to it Russell
Crowe's quote from the Man of Steel
perfectly defines Superman in saying you
will give the people of Earth an ideal
to strive towards they will race behind
you they will stumble they will fall but
in time they will join you in the sun in
time you will help them accomplish
wonders
[Music]
so before we continue with this video we
do want to say thank you to our sponsor
Atlas VPN and right now you can have a
private Christmas and a safe new year
because you can get atlas VPN premium
for just a buck 70 a month plus six
months extra with a 30 day money back
guarantee now this is the best Atlas VPN
offer of the year so make sure you guys
are quick and make sure that you get
your deal by clicking on the link in the
video description because it's a limited
time offer now I know what you guys are
thinking does Rob really use Atlas VPN
yes I actually use Atlas VPN because
these things are dead useful and I love
using this because it's so affordable so
one of the great things about a VPN
specifically even Atlas VPN is Geo
restriction as a lot of you guys know
different companies out there will only
allow certain parts of the world to
access different types of content and if
you're an American that decides to
travel abroad to some place like London
or if you're somebody from London who
decides to travel to the United States
or any combination of any Nations across
the world you guys know that you may not
be able to access content across the
internet from your home country while
Atlas VPN makes that entirely possible
for you now this also comes with other
benefits like being able to block
malware or being able to hide your IP
address from other services and it's
insanely cool because it actually keeps
companies from being able to track you
which is really what I think is one of
the better things here so again with the
Christmas deal they're running you can
get atlas VPN for just a buck 70 a month
plus six months extra with a 30 day
money back guarantee and again it's the
best Atlas VPN offer of the year so make
sure you guys are quick and get your
deal by clicking the link below this
inside the video description because it
really is a limited time offer but with
that being said guys let's get back into
our video and so all of that being said
with James Gunn and DC films relaunching
Superman what should their inspiration
be what kind of Superman should they
present to the world well if Superman's
been around for almost a hundred years
he certainly has no shortage of stories
to adapt but only a few really stand at
the top of the list in my mind the feel
of James Gunn Superman should draw from
three stories Superman For All Seasons
peace on Earth and All-Star Superman
now starting with a Superman For All
Seasons the beauty of this story is its
Simplicity the origin of Superman is
ingrained in us as American society
almost as if we're born with this
knowledge and instead of focusing on the
destruction of Krypton a Superman For
All Seasons takes place almost entirely
in Smallville there are events that take
place in Metropolis and they do
influence some of the things that happen
in Smallville but the emphasis is placed
on Superman's Hometown the importance of
this town the people in his life and how
the lessons of his friends and family
transformed him from a small town boy
with Incredible powers to the hero that
stands as an inspiration to both
humanity and the larger superhero
community
Superman for all seasons has no
questions of whether or not Humanity's
worth saving there's no angst broodness
or cynicism towards the human race
instead Superman's initial concern about
using his powers out in the world are
focus on whether or not Humanity will
accept him and if he's even ready for
that level of responsibility
but if Superman For All Seasons focuses
on Clark coming to terms with his powers
and his role in the world peace on Earth
shows how he handles adversity
this story follows Superman in his
efforts to solve world hunger and while
he doesn't succeed and his efforts are
ultimately sabotaged there are no fights
with doomsday or dark side and there is
no Lex Luthor's shining green Kryptonite
in his face instead Superman's adversity
comes in realizing that he can't force
Humanity to stop fighting Wars he cannot
permanently prevent a dictator from
seizing the donated food for himself he
cannot change human nature but instead
of ending with a feeling of hopelessness
the story ends with Superman recognizing
that the best he can do is try to show
Humanity a better way and recognizing
that for every one person who stood in
his path two people thanked him for his
actions and so finally All-Star Superman
is arguably the greatest Superman story
ever written and while it does contain
your standard fare of Superman vs the
bad guy style conflicts its largest
emphasis is on Superman's impending
death his legacy and the world he leaves
behind it's in effect the conclusion of
everything that makes Superman Superman
giving Lois Lane his powers for 24 hours
allows her to experience the world
through his eyes to see and hear as he
does the cries for help the songs of his
praise and the pain of doing what he can
where he can but knowing he can't be
there for everyone during that time Lois
had never felt more connected to both
Superman and humanity and the world Lex
Luthor is granted a momentary view of
what the world could look like from
Superman's perspective and its beauty is
enough to bring Lex Luthor to tears to
tell the truth the Superman that we've
seen over the course of the dceu is not
the worst that we've ever seen and I
want to be clear in saying that not
everything about his depiction was bad
but Superman is not supposed to be
flawed sure he doesn't always know what
the right answer is to every question
but unlike humans who are flawed who are
reactionary who only realize an action
was a mistake after we've committed to
that act Superman should represent hope
for a better tomorrow and a hope for
what Humanity can become